[Music]
when I'm skating with these women I feel
on fire
I love rollerskating so much that I
decided that I was going to bring it
back for everyone i'm michelle stylin
better known as estrogen and i'm the
founder of moxie roller skates there are
21 skaters on the moxie skate team
worldwide but some of them are pigeon
Indy JAMA Jones
smelly and mutt legs anything that's
experimental or outside of what you've
probably seen on roller skates is what
we do roller skating was really really
big until I was born and then it really
kind of dropped off when rollerblades
came in roller skate innovation just
stopped
roller derby was the next new sport to
come to the roller skating industry the
seats that they were selling the roller
derby skaters were made for speed the
skates that we're making now are made
for secure landings for high-flying
tricks you know a few years ago their
work with gal stealing backflips and on
their own wheels and now there are and
I'm amazed at what my body can do I
really am we are chasing our dreams
we're chasing that feeling that
wonderful floaty feeling of being alive
and you will get that from roller skinny
it's this strange new feeling that's
refreshing oh this is
[Music]